[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du long vieux cash nous vous parlerons
de tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure d'unir nos deux singes
le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages on a l'impression
qu'on descend des chimpanzés et pas du
tout les chimpanzés et nous savons
cousin à grand mère maternelle qui était
bretonne me disais si toi tu descendu sa
joie sûrement pas révélé nous a secret
vous en avez mangé du mammouth je me
trouve à fouiller en sibérie et puis un
bon matin dans le trou que j'avais
commencé à creuser je trouve de lait
tout comme ce quelque chose de bien les
grands en filaments je suis à donner je
râle je dirais que ce sont des collègues
russes qui sont venus tripatouiller le
fond de ma recherche et puis à force de
tirer dessus comme rien ne venait je me
suis aperçu que j'étais sur le dos
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée
n'oubliez pas de réagir sera le
télégramme d'ayrté france ne pouvait
prendre part au débat est interpellé
nous inviter au sommaire de ce mercredi
27 octobre le projet doit sur le passé
ni terres face à une nouvelle étape
demain devant le sénat et la bataille
parlementaire qui s'annonce féroce
certains sénateurs et l'air veulent
exclure de la loi toute prolongation au
delà du 28 février olivier vers en veut
toujours lui son maintien jusqu'au 31
juillet le ministre de la santé qui a
reçu sa troisième dose antique au bide
en fin de journée allez-y at il exhorté
une façon d' incident et vous inciter à
la vaccination pour
palier à la hausse des contaminations ou
de nous préparer peut-être à la
troisième injection pour tous ce soir on
vous pose justement la question étant
devenu dépendant du vexin on attend vos
réactions sur le compte et dégradent rt
france
le sort de julian assange de nouveaux
enjeux au royaume uni la justice
britannique examine en appel la demande
d'extradition des états unis dix mois
après un premier refus le lanceur d
alerte fondateur de wikileaks presque
cent soixante quinze années de prison
outre atlantique pour avoir divulgué des
milliers de documents américains classés
secret défense on retrouvera notre
envoyé spécial katia technique en direct
de londres a
après les policiers de lyon il ya deux
jours c'est au tour de ceux des chansons
d'être pris pour cible des scènes
d'émeute impressionnante la nuit
dernière dans cette ville normande
traditionnellement calme une quinzaine
de véhicules ont été incendiées les
pompiers gendarmes et policiers visés
par des tirs de mortiers d'artifices des
violences urbaines qui font suite au
démantèlement d'un points de deal de
simple fait divers qui se succèdent ou
bien un véritable fléau qui s'amplifie
on tentera d'y voir plus clair dès 21h
[Musique]
la prolongation du pass sanitaire au
centre d'une bataille parlementaire
après les débats houleux à l'assemblée
nationale les sénateurs discuteront
demain du projet de loi de vigilance
sanitaire on retrouve à notre reporter
du cas légers devant le sénat bonsoir
lucas et à la veille et donc de ces
discussions un rassemblement ait lieu en
fin de journée pour dire l'ont une
nouvelle fois la prolongation de ce pass
annie terre
oui absolument il ya eu plusieurs
personnes plusieurs centaines de
personnes à partir de 17h et jusqu'à
maintenant il ya encore quelques grappes
de manifestants qui qui s'en vont des
personnes rassemblées ici pour faire
pression sur les sénateurs à l'appel du
parti les patriotes de florian philippot
la semaine dernière il était devant
l'assemblée nationale pour les mêmes
raisons je vous propose d'écouter ce que
m'ont dit ces manifestants le pass and i
ter dont l'objectif officiel était la
baisse
de la contamination et la prévention
d'une pseudo quatrième vague n'a eu
comme simple effet que d'augmenter le
taux de vaccinés parce que sous la
contrainte avec l'obligation vaccinale
et avec les contraintes de passes
sanitaires aujourd'hui donc il est
absolument illégitime que ninon députés
ni nos sénateurs ne votent la
prolongation la loi en discussion est ni
plus ni moins qu'à destruction de nos
acquis sociaux et sociétaux c'est une
loi fondamentale la constitution vie en
train d'être détruite détricoté par nos
parlementaires et aujourd'hui nous
sommes devant le sénat pour mettre les
sénateurs devant leurs responsabilités
ils doivent protéger les intérêts du
peuple ils doivent les protéger en
étudiant la loi et surtout en retoquant
tout ce qui est anticonstitutionnelle
si le texte est passé sans trop de
difficultés devant l'assemblée nationale
ça pourrait être différent devant le
sénat le rapporteur du texte philippe
basse a déposé plusieurs amendements
pour que cette loi prenne fin au 28
février et non pas au 31 juillet comme
le veut le gouvernement ça c'est une
revendication du parti et l'air
notamment ces personnes veulent que le
gouvernement est bien rendre des comptes
qui n'est pas les mains libres pendant
une période beaucoup trop longue autre
changement par rapport au texte il veut
conditionner les mesures au seul
département qui ont moins de 75% de la
population vaccinée c'est à dire environ
la moitié des départements à l'heure
actuelle il veut aussi un critère
d'incidence pour
pouvoir instaurer ces mesures la version
du sénat veut aussi supprimer la
possibilité pour les chefs
d'établissement de connaître le statut
vaccinal des élèves il estime qu' il
estime en tout cas en l'occurrence
philippe bas c'est derrière lui le parti
et l'air que et bien cela pose un
problème pour poser un problème de
discrimination est le cas le ministre de
la santé qui n'en finit pas lui de
défendre ce projet de loi
absolument hier il est temps devant la
commission des lois du sénat ils étaient
auditionnés
il a notamment expliqué que les mesures
sanitaires permettait de réduire
d'environ 30% l'incidence du virus la
circulation du virus sans ces mesures il
estime que nous serions à un seuil bien
au delà supérieur aux cinq mille cas par
jour pour lui il faut pouvoir recourir à
ces outils pendant toute la période
hivernale et même au delà car il y a des
variants qui font planer le doute qui
font planer des incertitudes notamment
le y 4.271 sous variant de variants
delta qui circulent en angleterre et
puis nous avons appris hier que jean
françois delfraissy avait fait une
enquête sur les hôpitaux et que il avait
été constaté que possiblement 20 % des
lits ne pouvaient pas être utilisées en
raison du manque de personnel alors une
des raisons qui a évoqué c'est notamment
des démissions après eh bien cette
période qui a été extrêmement éprouvante
pour le personnel hospitalier et le cas
olivier veyrat qui a aussi voulu inciter
à la troisième dose de vaccin
absolument il s'est fait vacciner avec
aussi le vaccin contre la grippe et il a
incité donc les personnes qui sont
éligibles à cette troisième dose à le
faire le gouvernement trouve que cette
cette campagne de rappel n'est pas assez
rapide il y a seulement 2.5 millions de
personnes qui ont fait ce rappel sur les
6 8 millions éligibles et puis il
pourrait y avoir aussi dans très peu de
temps et bien l'ouverture de la
vaccination aux enfants entre 5 et 11
ans il ya notamment aux états unis et le
vaccin fire qui est sur le point nous
dit-on d'être autorisée et stéphane
bancel a répondu à une interview en
france disant que sa version pour les
enfants du vaccin moderna s'était pas de
pincettes donc pdg de moderna et bien
avait une bonne balance bénéfice risque
si le cas légers en direct depuis le
scénar olivier verrons bien s'ils donc à
une troisième dose alors que certains
français dénoncent des effets
secondaires suite à une vaccination
complète ce soit nous donnons la parole
à ceux qui se disent sceptiques pour
notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de marc boyer qui présente un
schéma vaccinal complet mais selon lui
sa femme aurait développé une maladie de
prion après la deuxième injection du
vaccin seither son témoignage au micro
des stèles farges avant de recevoir nos
invités pour en débattre justement je
suis à breuil sur verre dans l'oise je
vais rencontrer marc doyer la vie de cet
homme a changé du tout au tout il y a
quatre mois et il va nous expliquer
pourquoi bonjour marc voyer bonjour
merci beaucoup de bien vouloir témoigner
sur notre antenne alors vous votre vie a
été bouleversée début juin si vous
pouvez nous raconter pourquoi puisque
mon épouse et a commencé à tomber malade
quinze jours après une injection du
vaccin fighter et entre juin et
maintenant ça c'est énormément dégradé
heureusement avec une maladie très grave
à prions où il n'y a pas de traitement
donc
à l'issue finale qui est un décès alors
à partir du moment où
votre femme est tombée malade comment
est-ce que vous en êtes venu à la
conclusion que c'était dû au vaccin déjà
parce que je pose la question aux dents
longues et j écoutais est-ce qu' il peut
y avoir un rapport avec le vaccin et ce
jour là ils me répondent oui peut-être
on sait pas
c'est possible
mais de toute façon on verra bien
s'il ya une augmentation des cas donc
c'est quand même c'est à la fois c'est
une réponse honnête mais c'est un petit
peu entre guillemets farfelu quand même
logique on est dans un grand délire
lentillac on sait pas notre médecin
traitant a considéré que le cheminement
est que au niveau du calendrier de
de la déclaration de cette maladie pour
mon épouse il y avait quelque chose de
pas normal mon médecin traitant a fait
une déclaration
donc sur le site du ministère de la
santé je crois en déclarant que c'était
un cas suspect donc si vous les jeux
aujourd'hui je suis pas devant vous
comme
on risque peut-être de vouloir faire
passer ou comme un fantaisiste ou un
complotiste au quotidien je vis
une situation qui est
effroyable c'est un tortueux je souhaite
ça à personne je préfèrerais me tromper
et sincèrement me dire que mon épouse
c'est le fruit du hasard c'est devenu
quoi aujourd'hui votre quotidien mon
quotidien c'est d'attendre mon épouse
décède voilà c'est terrible e
c'est mon quotidien c'est dans ce coup
je me réveille le matin
elle a un saignement de nez d'une et
jusqu'en bas de la jouer là je me dis qu
elle en train de faire une hémorragie
cérébrale parce que je suis pas médecin
et donc je lui dis mais non ça ne me
laisse pas me laisse pas tomber
maintenant c'est trop tôt c'est de
surveiller voyez mon téléphone avec une
caméra parce que je peux plus sortir
même dans mon jardin parce qu'elle se
tape des crises d'angoissé effroyable et
que si je suis pas là pour la rassurer
les prises angoisse elles vont durer
pendant je sais pas combien de temps et
que elle peut arracher sa perfusion qui
pour l'instant la maintient on va pas la
sauver mais lui assure un certain
confort
mon quotidien c'est mon fils qui quand
il voit sa mère aux fonctions il ya deux
jours et me dit tu sais pas pas toutes
façons maman allait presque elle est
presque déjà morte
c'est une torture
essayer d'entendre
un ministre à qui j'ai sincèrement
demander de l'aide
même pas être capable de me de me
rappeler et de continuer de tas de dire
que ce que je vis ça peut être un hasard
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
l'impression d'être seuls pour gérer
cette situation non de moins en moins
parce que je reçois énormément de
messages de soutien de témoignages de
partout même de l'étranger des antilles
et je vais vous montrer d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui vous avez reçu combien de
messages peu près de témoignages qui
prise de gens qui présentent les mêmes
problèmes que j'ai très peu joué alors
depuis vendredi les mêmes problèmes que
mon époux j'en ai reçu 2 je vais vous
dire celui-là qui est importante je
voulais vous informer que mon frère a
été dans le même cas vacciner fighter
mi-avril premiers symptômes
neurologiques semaine suivante est un
mental dégradé début mai hospitalisation
mi-mai diagnostic maladie creutzfeldt
jakob début juin 17 23 juin je tenais à
vous témoigner pour faire avancer la
recherche cordialement ça c'est le
premier dans quel état d'esprit est ce
que vous êtes aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
vous ressentez est ce que c'est de la
colère est ce que c'est de la tristesse
non je fais un mélange de peine de
colère de détresse j'ai pas d'esprit de
vengeance je veux simplement que soit
reconnue
les victimes voilà parce que je
considère que les gens victimes de
vaccins on doit les considérer comme des
victimes et pas en faire des
complotistes je suis pas je peux pas me
positionner activement comme un
quelqu'un anti vaccins mais je trouve
que le rôle du politique et le rôle en
général de tous ceux qui décident de
notre santé c'est avant tout nos
protégés et on peut pas simplement se
contenter de dire oui mais ça va sauver
plus de gens que ça va en tuer non parce
que là on est sur des pathologies graves
avec derrière des drames humains donc
c'est pas mon job mais c'est le leur ils
ont été élus pour ça donc maintenant
c'est avait trouvé une solution et je
veux moi qui je lance un appel là pour
le coup aux députés
je trouve que les éléments que j'ai
apporté là et tout ce que j'ai collecté
ça mériterait de lancer rapidement une
enquête parlementaire voilà parce qu'on
peut pas continuer comme ça merci
beaucoup un reportage signé estelle fage
alors que l'épidémie de covin montre en
tout cas des signes de reprise en france
comme ailleurs en europe les
hospitalisations sont en légère hausse
mais faut-il intégrer la troisième dose
au pass sanitaire alors que certains
français se montrent s'équipent sommes
nous devenus dépendants du vaccin on
attend vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme d'ayrté france le face à face
c'est maintenant
[Musique]
et avec mon pour en parler philippe
froguel chercheur généticien fini
regrette vous êtes professeur à
l'impérial collège de londres et à
l'université lille 2 bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous elle a ouvert sur ce
plateau sénateurs les républicains de
côte d'or bon soir là où père merci à
vous également nous accompagner ce soir
un mot philippe froguel sur ce
témoignage qu'on vient d'entendre un
certain français c'est un secret
évidemment pour personne on les entend
d'ailleurs aussi sur d'autres médias
sont sceptiques pensent que la
vaccination peut être dangereuse vous
leur répondez quoi en tant que
professeur grand défenseur du mc st
d'abord c'est incroyable ce qui était ce
qui arrive à cette famille à je ne sais
pas si c'est une coïncidence et les
vaccins donne une stimulation
immunitaire et parfois on voit bien à
dans le diabète de type 1 on a une
apparition de la maladie apparente juste
après qu'ils aient simplement lié au
fait que ce développement l'immunité
fait venir une main il maladie qui de
toute façon serait elle serait apparue
plus tard mais ça donne l'impression que
c'est que c'est lié je dirais simplement
que healy a possiblement mais là c'est
pas du tout prouvé des effets
secondaires rarissime de la vaccination
anti-grippe au vide c'est absolument
terrible que ça peut tomber chez
n'importe qui mais que le bénéfice net
de la vaccination est absolument énorme
et a sauvé des millions de vies dans le
monde est hélas ya certain nombre de
gens qui font des complications des
myocardique par exemple ça a été montré
à peut rien y faire il ya la même chose
dans d'autres types de vaccination et à
l'eau chaude dans plein de médicaments
qui sauvent des vies mais en tue
quelques-uns et l'as tous les
médicaments
ont des effets secondaires et ça c'est
dramatique jeu mais il faut considérer
le bénéfice net pour tous les autres cas
en tout cas de me doyer on parle d'un
cas sur un million je parle sur votre
contrôle évidemment mais mais les
témoignages
voilà quand ils sont là font font mal
est-ce qu'il faut faire une enquête
parlementaire alain houpert quand vous
entendez ce type de témoignage ça vous
inspire quoi vous n'êtes pas un fan
évidemment du passé ni terre on va en
parler mais vous n'êtes pas contre le le
vaccin bien évidemment d'abord je
voudrais vous remercier de
passer sur reportage comme l'a dit le
professeur froguel c'est effroyable
c'est émouvant
l'auditeur a parlé de de bénéfice risque
mais le problème dans ce bénéfice risque
on nous parle jamais du risque et en
médecine
puisque nous sommes tous les deux
médecins cher cher confrère
on a été éduqué par le par le doute et
de bénéfice du doute il est important
pour progresser l'écouté des gens et
quand on regarde les donner
quand on regarde les données européennes
de phison ya un demi million de
complications avec ce vaccin des graves
des noms grave du bénigne et il faut le
prendre en compte pour progresser dans
la vaccination est la problématique
c'est que
reparler du passé ni terre évidemment je
suis contre le ps sanitaire et être
contre le passé ni terre c'est remettre
en cause la politique vaccinale du
gouvernement et tant que l'on n'aura pas
remis en cause cette politique vaccinale
on ne pourra jamais parler des effets
secondaires du vaccin au risque d'être
comédie auditeurs un complotiste je
crois qu'il faut relever la tête se met
tout son sens arrêtez de diviser la
france entre ceux qui sont pour entre
ceux qui sont contre ce que la france
est divisée la france elle est dans une
crise épidémique mais dans une crise
sociale psychologique grave il faut se
remettre tous ensemble et puis
travailler réfléchir évidemment il faut
une commission pour les commissions
c'est pas là pour enterrer les choses ça
doit être là pour progresser une
commission fait de professionnels de
parce qu'il ya une commission sur le
comité j'ai regardé la liste des gens
qui étaient invités on a évité des
préfets des ars quelques médecins peu de
chercheurs et chercheurs qui savent ce
que c'est qu'une molécule qui savent ce
que c'est qu'un chromosomes
je crois qu'il faut progresser on
[Musique]
il faut s'obstiner à chercher toujours
cherché est là on perd souligne voilà le
fait qu'en france on parle peut-être pas
assez d des risques et ce qui ouvre
peut-être justement la porte à des à des
théories parfois
conspirationnistes il est sain justement
d'en parler peut-être parce que vous
l'avez dit vous-même il existe parfois
des risques comme sur tous les vaccins
et surtout de les expliquer
il faut bien entendu parler et dire la
vérité aux gens et le fait que depuis le
début de l'épidémie et pouvoirs publics
ont eu des discours pour le moins
variable par exemple sur le masque
sa entraîneur que le public à peu
confiance
la troisième dose moi je suis à fond
pour la troisième ou de rouge on a
montré en israël comme quoi c'était
efficace pour combattre le variant delta
mais je comprends très bien que beaucoup
de gens ne le fasse pas on leur a vanté
que le vaccin c'est l arme absolue est
donc ce n'est pas leur absolue c'est une
arme très efficace mais certainement pas
absolue et si on avait expliqué aux gens
à la vérité vous connaissez peut-être
pas mais qu'on aille pas fait semblant
de croire que tout était géniale et bien
les gens n'aurais pas cru que de toute
façon c'était fini des puzzles faire
cette troisième dose que je veux dire
c'est que dire la vérité au public en
tout cas ce qu'on sait c'est toujours la
meilleure solution
parce qu'à long terme c'est ce qui est
le plus efficace et je suis pas du tout
sûr qu'on ait fait ça depuis un an et
demi et c'est ce qu'on fait en tout cas
ce soir on va faire un point sur
l'épidémie en tout cas de kobe de car
les indicateurs clignotent en regarder
cette alerte de kovy deux tracker sur
les réseaux sociaux
élément confirmant une hausse de
l'activité épidémique les formes graves
sont de nouveau en hausse depuis une
semaine 220 admission chaque jour à
l'hôpital + 14% en une semaine cinquante
et une admission chaque jour en soins
critiques + 12 % en une semaine mais
regardez un dans le prolongement la
courte qu'il publiait près donc une
longue descente et bien on voit qu'elle
est en phase ascendante on va donc
peut-être avoir une cinquième vague cet
hiver on souhaite pas mais mais c'est la
crainte d'alain houpert c'est pour ça
que le gouvernement veut prolonger le
pass annie terre jusqu'en juillet
inciter à la vaccination ce n'est pas
nécessaire devant ces chiffres on a
parlé de première une première
de premières vagues qui est une balle
mortelle parce que on a refusé tout
traitement on a laissé les gens chez jeu
avec du doliprane alors qu'on aurait pu
ne serait-ce que les assistés arrêt
respiratoire mans leur donner des
anticoagulants leur donner des
corticoïdes ensuite il ya eu la seconde
la troisième et la quatrième c'est une
vague une vague mathématiques
puisqu'elle a été créée par suite au
discours du président de la république
où les gens sont allés se faire tester
et on a vu qu'on avait des gens qui
étaient positifs mais non non malades
donc j j'ai peur dans dans les discours
du gouvernement et quand je voit
l'acharnement du gouvernement à
convaincre les gens c'est qu'il ya un
problème
il faut raison garder et si le vaccin
marchait si bien on n'aurait pas besoin
de troisième dose et
et le vaccin dire que le vaccin est le
seul la seule issue
pour une épidémie
jamais appris ça en médecine parce que
sinon la grippe ne tuerait pas quinze
mille personnes par an et
ne qu'on n'aurait pas de miss 2002
millions
5,2 contaminés par an et puis
la grippe serait qu'un souvenir je pense
que cette année nous aurons peut-être
plus de morts de la grippe que duke aux
ide donc je pense que je dénonce c'est
le discours alarmiste du gouvernement
qui affole les gens les gens ils ont
peur c'est le discours de la peur
philippe froguel quand alain houpert
body c'est peut-être le vaccin n'est pas
assez efficace c'est peut-être aussi
pour aller plus loin que le vaccin n'est
pas efficace assez longtemps
que maintenant que pour les personnes
qui ont été vaccinées en janvier qui ont
plus de 60 70 ans ou un certain nombre
de ces gens il ya une baisse de
l'immunité c'est pour ça que la
troisième dose a été fait qui est très
efficace tant en israël à israël a une
une vague énorme à malgré la vaccination
ils ont revacciner une grande partie de
la population d'âge moyen et élevé et là
maintenant il ya une diminution très
importante des cas et des cas graves
donc oui ces vaccins
sont c'est comme le vaccin pour la
grippe 1 ça dure ça doit pas très
longtemps est un des problèmes
heureusement on peut le refaire et on
peut espérer dans ce cas là on restera
ces chiffres relativement bas 2 au
cameroun avant de faire hospitaliser et
pas de garantie complètement c'est pour
ça que moi je suis pour le passé ni
terra mais surtout je suis pour l'ibpt
et gestes barrières notamment les
masques en intérieur pour
éviter que ce virus très très très
contagieux se passe d'une personne à
l'autre même vacciné avec un risque
quand même qu'on soit un mois je connais
des gens qui ont été à
vacciner et se sont payé
encore à un épisode de koh vide au
cinéma il ya quelques semaines à une
personne porter le masque sont restées
2h30 avoir un avoir un film et donc les
aérosols sont entraîne à un risque de
son faire
atteindre à nouveau par par la maladie
ce sim parfois malgré la vaccination
dont il n'y a pas de mesure miracle
pardonnez moi ça veut dire que pour
revenir à la question de départ de ce
débat ça veut dire concrètement que nous
sommes devenus dépendants au vaccin et
il va falloir renouveler tous les six
mois des doses vous n'avez pas porter
français se lassent
et entendu qu'ils vont se lasser se sont
déjà là c'est d'ailleurs puisqu'on a le
gouvernement qui a pas fait d'ailleurs
une grande campagne pour ça on n'a pas
réussi à atteindre ses objectifs de
revalidation des personnes âgées on a
une sorte de course de vitesse
aujourd'hui à on espère qu'après cet
hiver qu'il faut pas qu'il faudra passer
de toute façon là la pandémie va
atteindre il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
véritablement de variants très dangereux
le delta plus ça n'arrive pas à percer
parce qu'il est finalement pas plus
contagieux que le delta
il faut faire ce que nous pouvons de
manière modeste mais déterminée au passé
l'hiver est à espérer que au printemps
prochain la pandémie se terminera et se
terminent toujours cette pandémie mais
la question à se poser c'est combien de
personnes vont mourir d'ici là on vient
on faire des copies de l'an et c'est
celle-là il faut essayer d'agir le mieux
possible
les français sont devenus dépendants de
belles paroles et des craintes en 8 par
ce gouvernement c'est un message que
vient de mon post et david sur notre
compte rt télégramme vous êtes
évidemment d'accord avec ce postulat
vous ne disiez il n'empêche alain
houpert aujourd'hui le pdg de moderne à
stéphane bancel nous dit selon moi il
faut vacciner les jeunes enfants si on
regarde ce qu'il s'est passé aux états
unis où il a eu beaucoup plus de cas de
delta qu'en france presque 20 % des
américains hospitalisés étaient des
enfants ce qui n'était pas du tout le
cas avec la souche originel
que vous inspire cette sortie c'est
surprenant c'est surprenant de voir dans
le parisien
un journal qui appartient à une des plus
grandes fortunes de france
qui elle aussi a investi en 2016 dans
l'entreprise moderna de voir ne
serait-ce pas au delà de l'article de
voir un chapeau ou le pdg stéphane
bancel moderna conseille la vaccination
aux enfants de
modern a engrangé plus de 2 milliards
d'euros de fortune personnelle monsieur
vencel c'est l'équivalent d'une campagne
de vaccination complète d'un pays comme
la france
la position de stéphane bancel c'est la
position d'un investisseur c'est pas la
position d'un médecin j'aurais aimé le
parisien
interview un médecin thériault le
professeur froguel et quand le maître
quant au vaccin ne révèle des réacteurs
ne révèle ne relève plus du commerce
quand il devient obligatoire
et les profits je suis un je suis un
libéral mais là il ya une obligation
les profits devraient être au service de
la recherche je suis d'accord avec le
professeur fogiel est pas d'accord sur
certains points d'accord sur le fait
qu'il a dit qu' il ya une urgence
d'accélérer séquençage des variants pour
éviter de se faire déborder par la
maladie et il faut que la technocratie
laisse la place à la médecine
il faut s'engager dans la recherche de
traitements et arrêter de croire que le
vaccin est la seule solution et je suis
heureux dans cette cacophonie entre
scientifiques que mon confrère être
adopté une position honnête et impartial
et monsieur le professeur froguel et
contre le professeur raoul tu es il n'a
pas été agressif et indécent ce qui lui
a valu dans les réseaux sociaux des
attaques des gens qui étaient probables
sein des attaques excessives et voilà je
j'apprécie sa neutralité je suis
d'accord avec lui mais je ne suis pas
d'accord avec lui sur
combler les trous vaccinale on va lui
poser la question justement philippe
froguel sur cette sortie de de stéphane
bancel à qui on va pas se mentir peut
inquiéter chaque parent qui nous dit
presque 20 % des américains hospitalisés
étaient des enfants philippe froguel
maintenant le virus est dangereux aussi
pour les enfants on nous dit constamment
le contraire qui croire
à la situation américaine et pas celle
de la france beaucoup d'enfants sont
très obèses aux etats unis beaucoup
viennent de minorités qui sera plus
grand risque de le faire dès des formes
graves et nous on n'a pas 20 % d'adp
d'enfance dans les hôpitaux un rapport
aux adultes donc c'est cette situation
américaine n'est pas la situation
française moi je n'ai aucune religion
concernant la vaccination des enfants de
cinq ans j'aurais tendance à penser qu'
il faut attendre un peu et voir ce qui
se passe a surtout protéger les grands
parents c'est pour ça que moi je suis
pour la revaccination des grands parents
parce que c'est eux qui seront en
contact avec mes enfants d'autre part a
que des jeunes face la maladie ça
servira en angleterre il y en a à peu
près 80% des quarante mille par jour
mais il garde relativement peu d'adultes
aujourd'hui qui meurt donc faut toujours
penser
à l'intérêt de faire les choses à un
bénéfice risque moi je pense pas que ce
serait dangereux pour les enfants mais
est peut-être dangereux pour la paix
sauf que faire ce qu'on peut avec les
armes actuelles avant de de penser avoir
de nouvelles armes et je suis bien
d'accord sur une chose il n'ya pas de la
vaccination il ya les gestes barrières
les traitements pour l'instant on n'a
pas été efficace là dessus nous à
l'institut pasteur de lille on teste un
traitement elle beaucoup de retard parce
que on nous a empêché de le faire depuis
neuf mois mais maintenant ça a commencé
et très compliqué une pandémie nouvelle
on a fait beaucoup de choses mais à une
certain nombre de bêtises et on s'est
beaucoup disputé alors qu'on n'aurait
pas dû je pense simplement que il faut
analyser sereinement la situation et et
au jour le jour cette question de passer
unitaire jusqu'en juin
personnellement je serais plutôt
d'accord de le faire que jeu jusqu'en
février comme le propose le sénat a et
de revoir après si on veut quand j'aurai
ce n'est qu'une question politique merci
beaucoup philippin forgan merci alain
houpert d'avoir été avec nous sur ce
plateau est justement parlé de
traitement la lutte contre le coc vie
qui pourrait bien passer par une pilule
désormais la france a passé une commande
massive auprès du laboratoire américain
merck
cinquante mille doses au total elles
seront livrées fin novembre ou début
décembre à un prix exorbitant alors que
le médicament n'a toujours pas reçu
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
regarder
[Musique]
là
ton
[Musique]
quand
lamy
[Musique]
m
les etats unis tentent une nouvelle fois
d'extrader julian assange après un
premier échec en janvier le sort du
fondateur de wikileaks est actuellement
entre les mains de la haute cour de
londres on retrouve notre envoyé spécial
au royaume-uni 4 ça pique nique bonsoir
katia à julian assange qui n'a donc pas
assisté à l'audience il avait pris un
médicament qui le rendait incapable de
suivre le procès mais il est apparu très
brièvement en vision escorté donc pas
ringarde
et oui c'est cela stéphanie tout à fait
alors comme il est apparu très amaigri
am émacié étrangers bien c'était un
signal très inquiétant pour ses soutiens
qui se sont regroupés aujourd'hui
et
le poids que le juge barry soeur à
donner aux professeurs kopelman étaient
exagérées et l'accusation n'a pas été en
mesure de mettre en lumière les faits et
elle a également été trompeuses pour la
cour et pourtant il y avait eu beaucoup
de considération de certains aspects de
tous les rapports de tous les
psychiatres dans le jugement du juge
marie soeur que julian ne soit pas
extradée respecte
johanne aubé extraites et katia quels
arguments juridiques ont été amenés
oui alors vous l'avez entendu par la
bouche du père de julian assange donc
ils ont cherché à discréditer le rapport
d'expertisé du psychiatre inquiète un
grand nom à de la psychiatrie est du
domaine juridique et qu'ils étaient
favorables à julian assange pourquoi
favorable parce que il évoqué un risque
suicidaire très fort et sous prétexte
qu'il ne mentionnait pas ce rapport la
présence d'une compagne et de deux
enfants est bien les états unis ont pu
faire appel alors aujourd'hui le
représentant des américains auprès de la
cour james lewis appuyé sur plusieurs
points notamment diplomatiques c'est un
peu l'enjeu de ce procès en affirmant
que la grande bretagne avait jusqu'ici a
pas eu à se plaindre de sa longue
coopération avec les américains et
surtout il a affirmé que les états unis
donneraient des assurances comme par
exemple celle de ne pas mettre de julian
assange à l'isolément et pourtant les
documents officiels qui sont produits
montre bien que les états unis peuvent
se réserver le droit d'imposer des
restrictions donc par exemple isolement
donc ce n'est pas vraiment un argument
qui tient et puis bien sûr ce
représentant a contesté la décision de
janvier de la juge estimant qu'elle
avait mal jugé des éléments concernant
la santé mentale détérioré de julian
assange alors ces arguments ont été très
rapidement contré par l'équipe de
défense de julian assange qui explique
au contraire la juge avait fait des
choix scrupuleux et qu'il y avait un
risque de suicides évidents et qu'en
fait les américains n'ont trouvé aucune
erreur légale dans la procédure et
qu'ils ont fait appel juste parce qu'ils
avaient échoué en première instance et
je vous propose maintenant un d'écouté
lors il a voulu c'est un hacker
britannique qui a fait comme julian
assange l'objet d'une demande
d'extradition des etats-unis pour
exactement les mêmes raisons qui a vécu
un véritable cauchemar
nous avons perdu dans le premier cas
contrairement à julian qui a gagné mais
doit encore attendre un appel ici et
c'était un procès sur les mêmes bases
mais il serait injuste et oppressif de
soumettre quelques uns aux mêmes
conditions auxquelles j'ai été où
seraient confrontés
alors stéphanie le programme de demain
c'est que l'équipe de julian assange va
s'employer à démonter l'argumentaire
américain et une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation se prépare devant la haute
cour aujourd'hui il y avait environ 500
personnes qui se sont relayés les un
concert des prises de parole à stella
mauricien la compagnie d'autres jeunes
assange qui a parlé de persécutions
politiques avaient des représentants
également de reporters sans frontières
est donc une deuxième journée encore de
soutiens à du hamas en jeu demain et on
suivra évidemment demain katia allons
pouvoir les derniers développements
merci également à aujourd'hui demory qui
vous accompagnent derrière la caméra
katia et le feuilleton assange qui dure
depuis plus de dix ans retour en images
sur cette longue affaire judiciaire
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
l'autre blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir clos
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
pour bien qu'on comprenne pourquoi le
royaume uni at il refusé jusque-là
l'extradition de julian assange
parce que julian assange est tombé sur
un sur une magistrate parfaitement
indépendantes comme le sont généralement
les magistrats en grande bretagne elle a
accueilli est là elle a réfuté tous les
arguments de la défense de hausse de
assange qui qui
visait à annihiler l'accusation de
l'administration américaine mais pour
autant elle a accueilli un rapport d'un
psychiatre qui jugeait que il serait
probablement dangereux d'extrader julian
assange parce que il était
psychologiquement fragile déprimée
probablement avec des tendances
suicidaires et que son incarcération aux
états unis d
interrogatoire très dur pour elle
l'inde a mené à a finalement mettre fin
à ses jours et c'est pourquoi elle avait
refusé l'extradition donc voilà pour le
premier épisode et aujourd'hui c'est
l'appel sur ce même motif est ce qu'il
est en état d'être extradé ou pas c'est
là dessus et les états unis
effectivement sont venus avec des
arguments aux nouveaux que vous avez
expliqué tout à l'heure à l'écran à
savoir que pendant sa longue son nom
confinement à l'ambassade d'équateur et
bien il a eu deux enfants il a une
compagne qui était son avocate et de
l'époque et par conséquent peut-être
n'était-il pas dans un état
psychologique si déprimée que cela alors
est ce que la haute cour de londres
pourrait décider cette froide de
répondre à la demande des états unis
alors la haute cour pourrait en effet
recevoir les arguments invoqués par
l'accusation par l'administration
américaine mais dans le fond le fait
d'avoir une compagne et d'avoir deux
enfants cela n'annule pas les expertises
du psychiatre qui a dit qu'il était au
moment où il a fait l'expertisé c'est à
dire au début de cette année déprimés
avec des tendances suicidaires donc il
est bien possible que la haute cour
décide comme la juge du mois de janvier
qu'il n'est pas en état d'être extradé
il y aura d'autres recoupements
washington le cas échéant oui il y a
d'autres recours il ya évidemment la
cour suprême britannique
si elle accepte de se saisir du sujet
elle n'est pas obligé de l'accepter elle
peut dire que dans le fond le tribunal
qui siège aujourd'hui un siégèrent en
dernier recours et de toute façon après
cela il faudra qu'à un signe pas
extradition il faudra qu'un tribunal
britannique juge sur le fond c'est à
dire quelles sont les fautes commises
assange est est-ce que c'est condamnable
en vertu du droit britannique ou droit
international alors julian assange
absents on l'avait on l'a dit avec 4 sa
technique à l'ouverture de l'audience
c'est un symbole très fort du cassis
pour confirmer ce que dit sa compagne de
son ancien avocat at elle dit en effet
qu'il est dans un état physique
d'épuisement total qui est en très
mauvais état et qu'il ne peut pas
comparaître normalement donc c'est la
confirmation de ses dires et
probablement que des médecins pourront
aussi confirmer ou infirmer pour le pour
que la cour siège est pas de sa décision
en connaissance de cause alors les
enjeux évidemment club blanchemaison
sont éminemment politique on le rappelle
les procédures contre julian assange ont
été lancées sous le mandat de donald
trump presse que ça peut changer le fait
qu'il y ait un autre président américain
moi je pense que c'est très politique
pour une raison tout à fait fondamental
c'est que quel état au monde peut
accepter que les secrets d'état soient
divulguées par un journaliste alors
effectivement c'est la liberté de la
presse
versus le secret des alertes beaucoup de
soutien voilà on peut effectivement
estimé que les secrets d'état devraient
disparaître à ce moment là la
correspondance des circuits un étatique
changer complètement de nature celle des
ambassadeurs celle des généraux sur les
théâtres d'opérations changerait de
nature s'il savait que ceci doit être
portée sur la place publique des
lendemains par conséquent je pense que
la plupart des états à des systèmes
étatiques souhaite qu'un crack un
système de
communications secrètes demeure sans
qu'il soit exposé à être immédiatement
mis sur la place publique et on peut
être d'un avis contraire et c'est ce
débat qui est actuellement a lieu entre
en effet les organisations qui défendent
les droits de l'homme et les états il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'états qui viennent
dire que ils sont prêts à renoncer à des
communications cryptées et à l'existence
de secret d'état sauf si évidemment on
utilise ce secret d'état pour couvrir
des crimes contre l'humanité et c'est un
peu ce que dit aux anges il dit que
l'armée américaine a commis des crimes
en afghanistan en irak et que c'est cela
qui l'a dénoncé au risque de mettre en
danger les gens dont les noms figuraient
dans ses communications qui l'a rendu
public les journaux qu'on utilisait ces
textes disent qu'ils ont c'est
soigneusement épuré c'était qui l'ont
enlevé tous les noms pour éviter que des
personnes soient mises en danger mais
évidemment on ne peut pas exclure que
certaines indications puisse être
utilisée pour mettre des vies en danger
merci claude gans maison d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous apporter votre
éclairage et à londres toujours et à
londres toujours les relations sont plus
que jamais difficile avec paris la
france vient d'annoncer vouloir prendre
des sanctions à l'encontre du royaume
uni dès le 2 novembre
en cause les autorisations de pêche post
break site dans les eaux britanniques
seuls ngola
la menace pesait depuis plusieurs
semaines sur londres ce mercredi paris a
décidé de la mettre en application
il ya une volonté manifeste qui est
exprimée de ne pas respecter l'accord
est de ne pas donner à nos pêcheurs qui
ont été très patients qui ont beaucoup
attendu qui ont été exemplaires les
licences auxquels ils ont droit nous
allons annoncer un certain nombre de
mesures qui rentreront en vigueur pour
certaines d'entre elles dès lundi peau
des à mardi prochain pour d'autres dans
les jours qui suivront objectif
contraindre le royaume uni à respecter
les autorisations de pêche dans ces
zones négocié avec la france dans
l'accord post précise au total 200
licences ont été accordées à des
pêcheurs français moins de la moitié du
nombre convenu fin 2020 sauf revirement
de londres d'ici au 2 novembre paris
entend mettre en place des contrôles
douaniers et sanitaires systématique sur
les produits importés en france et
l'interdiction de débarquement de
produits de la mer
pour accentuer la pression sur le
royaume-uni la france envisage d'ores et
déjà des restrictions sur ses
exportations d'énergie des annonces qui
pour le moment ne semble pas avoir créer
de remous au royaume uni
malgré les condamnations à
l'international de la politique
israélienne les projets de construction
d'appartements se multiplient en
cisjordanie occupée il serait elle
approuve et 1350 nouveaux logements pour
des colons juifs pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis tel aviv en
israël avec un pot la flyer journaliste
international c'est notre rubrique a vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir paul à ces nouveaux logements
qui doivent donc s'ajouter aux quelques
deux mille annoncées en août par les
autorités qui devrait obtenir cette
semaine un feu vert définitif du
ministère de la défense pourquoi la
construction d'autant de logements
aulas zoom et les seuils comme un joug
l'avait bien dit il s'agit du plus grand
nombre de constructions de nouveaux
logements à prouver pas l'état depuis
une décennie le ministre de la défense
israélien benny ganz explique que malgré
ce nombre élevé israël suit une
politique équilibrée de construction
d'une part israël n'a pas approuvé tous
les plans de construction en préparation
mais offre des coûts et aux offres
d'autre part des concessions aux
palestiniens
la raison de cette accélération de la
politique c'est l'augmentation
démographique israélienne
la population iranienne augmentent de 2
% par an c'est quatre fois la moyenne
des pays développés
dans la population israélienne doublera
d'ici à quelques temps
et israël est le deuxième pays le plus
densément peuplé du monde
fan qui avait connu un vif essor un saut
sous l'impulsion de mamie netanyahu
pendant l'ère trump comment les choses
vont évoluer
désormais
la croissance démographique
une certaine extension est inévitable
les etats unis ont émis des
critiques très sévères la lustration joe
biden a été plus clair que jamais disant
que cela était en contradiction totale
avec toutes les avancées vers la paix
entre les israéliens et les palestiniens
les palestiniens eux mêmes ont exprimé
beaucoup de colère vis-à-vis de ces
propositions israéliennes quel est le
regard de neuf tony bennett sur la
colonisation
le premier ministre israélien naftali
bennet émane de la droite de l'échiquier
politique israélien et à des vues très
similaire à celle de son prédécesseur
benyamin netanyahou il est en faveur du
développement de la des colonies
israéliennes
et encourage les colons à
continuer leur politique d'un pelé
minutes d'implantation
et malgré les critiques des etats-unis
la politique de colonisation devrait
continuer et devrait se poursuivre dans
le sillage des politiques sous benyamin
nétanyahou naftali bennet cependant en
tant que l'individu
n'a peut-être pas tout à fait le même
point de vue que sont les prédécesseurs
il mène une coalition politique très
fragile
il s'est rapproché du centre de la
gauche par rapport à sa position
initiale à droite mais il faut savoir
que sa coalition compte des partis de
gauche des partis arabes le parti
travailliste israélien et tous ces
partis sont résolument contre la
politique de colonisation
donc il fait face à des critiques venant
du sein de sa propre coalition donc il a
un certain équilibre à respecter
car il a une majorité très courte et ne
pourrait pas perdre ne serait-ce qu'un
seul siège à la knesset donc
équilibre à trouver entre sa volonté
d'expansion
et le fait qu'il doit à maintenir la
cohérence de sa coalition merci voilà
slayer en direct de tel aviv et les
états unis qui hausse le temps justement
face à israël sur cette question de la
colonisation on prend la direction de
washington on y retrouve notre
correspondante aux abonnés bonsoir
thomas washington qui s'opposent
clairement aux projets de logements
d'israël dans les colonies et c'est en
quelque sorte une rupture avec l'ère
trump
oui c'est un changement d'attitude de la
part de washington qui tranche
évidemment avec les positions qui
étaient prises à l'époque par donald
trump et c'est une des premières fois
parce que jusqu'à présent joe biden
s'était plutôt montré prudent sur le
dossier israélo-palestinien mais ce
mardi donc le porte-parole de la
diplomatie américaine à employé un ton
ferme à l'égard d'israël je propose de
l'écouter
nous sommes préoccupés par la
publication dimanche des appels d'offres
pour 1300 logements dans un certain
nombre de colonies en cisjordanie
nous nous opposons fermement à
l'extension des colonies qui est
totalement contraire aux efforts pour
faire baisser les tensions et garantir
le calme et qui nuit aux perspectives de
solution à deux états et les
morceaux nous estimons aussi que tout
effort visant à légaliser
rétroactivement des colonies illégales
et inacceptable nous continuons à faire
part de notre point de vue sur cette
question directement au haut
fonctionnaire israélien et lors de nos
discussions
alors cette prise de position de
l'administration de joe biden semble en
réalité s'inscrire dans la stratégie qui
était à l'époque celle de barack obama
mais évidemment cela tranche avec les
décisions qui ont été prises par donald
trump puisqu'il faut rappeler qu'en 2019
mike pompéo qui était le secrétaire
d'état américain sous la présidence de
donald trump avait déclaré que les états
unis ne considérait plus comme illégales
les colonies israéliennes en cisjordanie
et puis en 2020 il s'était même rendu
sur place pour une visite qui
s'inscrivent elles encore dans la
politique dans la stratégie nal trucks
relativement pro-israélienne il faut
aussi rappeler par exemple le
déplacement de l'ambassade américaine
dans la ville de jérusalem qui avait
provoqué on s'en rappelle beaucoup de
remous dans la région d'ailleurs sur ce
point précisément il faut noter qu'il
n'y a pas de remise en question de
retour en arrière prévues par
l'administration de joe biden il faut
aussi rappeler qu'il ya deux semaines le
ministre israélien des affaires
étrangères était en déplacement à
washington pour poursuivre la mise en
application des accords d'abraham ce
sont des accords qui ont été signés sous
la présidence de donald trump et qui
continuent à être mises en place par
l'administration de joe biden il ya donc
des limites à ce durcissement de ton de
la part de l'administration de joe biden
envers israël d'ailleurs il faut noter
que lors du discours donne est presque
est donc lieu hier malgré le ton ferme
qu'il a employés il est resté très
évasif sur les possibles actions que
pourrait entreprendre la diplomatie
américaine contre israël sur le dossier
des colonies merci thomas bonnet en
direct de washington
elle rester avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons des scènes
d'émeute impressionnante la nuit
dernière à alençon une quinzaine de
véhicules ont été incendiés pompiers
gendarmes et policiers ont été visés par
des tirs de mortiers d'artifice
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un choix pour les
inspecteurs du guide michelin de mettre
cette année en particulier voilà moscou
en avant et sur ces dernières années nos
inspecteurs ont pu noter une vraie
évolution de la scène culinaire de
moscou et puis de plus en plus de
concept de restaurant et avec des chefs
qui ont une vraie signature dans leur
cuisine c'est en observant ce
développement que vous êtes dit on va
aller voir de plus près ce qui se passe
en russie moscou est un vrai car fois un
vrai carrefour d'influencés un vrai
carrefour de deux cultures donc il ya un
vrai brassage donc il ya une très très
grande diversité des types de cuisine
moscou en particulier a une saveur
particulière a ajouté à la scène
gastronomique mondiale
autrefois on parlait de vertu
aujourd'hui on préfère les scandales
[Musique]
et si la prochaine crise financière
venait de chine evergrande c'est le nom
du géant chinois de la construction un
géant qui pourtant croule sous une
gigantesque dette tout va dépendre de la
façon dont l'état chinois va gérer la
chose est ce que il sauve les détenteurs
d'obligations en interne et qui plante
les détenteurs d'obligations
externe ou est ce que il règle la note
pour pour evergrande il suffit
quelquefois d'un maillot aux pumas ion
est gros plus c'est risqué d'un maillon
qui sautent dans cette chaîne pour avoir
des effets de propagation globaux
d'effet boule de neige nous sommes dans
un régime de prix administrés par les
banques centrales donc si vous voulez
200 milliards c'est rien pour une banque
centrale donc si elle veut régler le
problème evergrande demain et puis les
autres d'ailleurs un suffit qu'elle
fasse tourner la planche à billets et
aujourd'hui on est en train de tout
régler comme ça
[Musique]
ce personnage affreux tronics vous
l'avez créé en 2014 dans un but précis
montrer une autre image du continent
africain définitivement c'est d'essayer
de partir des racines de retour de chez
nous est montré que les jeunes africains
la génération peut aussi se projeter
dans le futur cela représente quoi pour
vous la ferez futurisme comme on n'a pas
eu une influence sur l'histoire sur le
passé on s'est dit on peut se permettre
d'imaginer un futur où l'afrique serait
un grand continent il ya pas moins de se
développer sans la culture
malheureusement ce qui sort du pays j'ai
la preuve que les médias s'intéressent
plus quand il s'agit de la guerre donc à
travers ma musique je veux inviter les
gens aient envie de découvrir ce beau
pays toy
m
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent là l on
soit vient de l'ignorance aujourd'hui
une gauche extrême musée le matin la
société
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
et
la communication des modèles mâcon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
victhom est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant poule et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont il se désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique pendant la
rendant encore plus quand on est
justement c'est une nouvelle forme de
communication assez verticale utiliser
des influenceurs pour moissac hommes
politiques personnelles est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vraiment nouveau
d'utiliser des célébrités pour faire de
la propagande politique on s'en fiche
nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige la
france comme si son travail en notre nom
pour nous aider dans notre intérêt à
tous
[Musique]
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire les policiers après les
policiers de lyon il y a deux jours
c'est au tour de ceux d'alençon d'être
pris pour cible des scènes d'émeute
impressionnante la nuit dernière dans
cette ville normande traditionnellement
calme une dizaine de véhicules ont été
incendiées les pompiers gendarmes et
policiers visés par des tirs de mortiers
d'artifices des violences urbaines qui
ferait suite au démantèlement d'un point
de lille
[Musique]
la ville d'alençon dans l'orne
d'ordinaire plutôt calme enlisé et donc
sous le choc au lendemain d'une nuit de
violences urbaines une quinzaine de
voitures ont été incendiées les
dernières carcasses de véhicules
calcinées ont été enlevés par les agents
tout à l'heure elle les pompiers
gendarmes et policiers ont été la cible
d'un guet-apens tendu par une trentaine
d'individus cagoulés vêtus de noirs dans
le quartier de perseigne aucun blessé
malgré des tirs de mortiers d'artifice
une enquête est ouverte pour déterminer
si ces violences font bel et bien suite
à une interpellation pour trafic de
stupéfiants écouter
dans les médias j'ai demandé des
renforts d'unités spécialisées qui sont
spécifiquement formés à ces violences
urbaines vont intervenir ils sont
présents dans quelques heures
voilà les habitants du quartier de
perseigne peuvent être assurés de la
plaine détermination qui est la mienne
de celle de monsieur le maire également
de monsieur puyo pour le vrai au service
de ses habitants et pour en parler nous
sommes avec ajoie kim thuy you mr ps
d'avancé bonsoir joaquim pueyo merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
en ont besoin d'entendre la préfète de
l'ordre qui a demandé des renforts
spécialisés après ces violences urbaines
tout d'abord où en est l'enquêté
à cette heure ci est ce que vous avez
des éléments nouveaux apportés lors se
mettant l'anc est super niveau du
programme public des autorités
judiciaires donc j'ai pas d'informations
précises mais il semble bien que les
conséquences de la garde à vue et de
l'interpellation d'un jeune qui avait
des produits toxiques sur lui de la
drogue en particulier
et l'origine de ces violences urbaines
qu'on a pu constater dans la nuit de
mardi à mercredi c'est un schéma
malheureusement classique c'est à dire
que vous avez des individus qui vivent
de l'argent facile qui font du trafic
avec des complices et qui ne veulent pas
absolument répondre aux dispositions
réglementaires donc lorsqu'ils ont
lorsqu'ils sont interpellés et bien pour
eux ce n'est pas normal et donc ils
réagissent ainsi et on l'a vu c'était
pour attirer la police dingue est
d'accord ce sont des groupes très
mobiles ils ont volé des voitures les
forces de police ont eu des difficultés
à intervenir les sapeurs-pompiers ont
été caillassés également donc là on est
vraiment dans une situation
et je peux dire que simplement que
l'état de droit doit s'appliquer donc il
faudra continuer bien évidemment à ce
que les lois républicaines soient mises
en oeuvre dans tous les quartiers et
dans tous les territoires ce qui me fait
ch c'est un une ville plutôt le disait
traditionnellement calme à ce que ces
épisodes sont inédits est ce que c'est
la première fois que vous vous les vivez
non ce n'est pas la première fois que
nous y vivons on a eu malheureusement
dans le passé des épisodes de également
similaire avec moins d'importance mais
c'est toujours lié à des interpellations
scellier souvent aaa à des trafics de
drogue également aimé le trafic s'est
amplifiée à mon avis depuis quelques
quelques années et donc je crois qu'il
est grand temps pour rouler pour eux
intervenir que les pouvoirs publics doit
s'atteler parce que on voit que hong
kong en grain les quartiers on voit que
nous avons un petit groupe d'individus
qui prennent en otage un quartier dans
ce quartier on a eu beaucoup de jeunes
qui ont témoigné qu'ils sont pas
d'accord bien évidemment qui s'est passé
nous sommes intervenus d'une manière
très forte dans les équipements
culturels dans les équipements sociaux
dans les équipements sportifs également
donc ça ce quartier caté reflet dans le
cadre de la rénovation urbaine dont
beaucoup d'investissement et quand je
vois ce constat évidemment on
s'interroge beaucoup sur la le respect
des lois sur l'état de droit et au delà
des véhicules comptait incendier c'est
une pensée pour les victimes parce que
ce sont des hommes et des femmes de
familles modestes utilisant véhicule
pour aller travailler ou la vue des
véhicules et utilité a également qui
sert à des artisans les entreprises qui
ont été incendiés non ce sont des faits
qui sont pas acceptables alors bien
évidemment on l'a demandé
les forces de police soient renforcés
pendant quelques jours mais je crois
qu'il ya un problème de fond qu'il
faudra poser bien évidemment quand on
observe qu'il ya des mineurs qui à deux
heures du matin 1h du matin incendié des
véhicules il ya également des questions
à se poser sur la responsabilité
également des familles bien évidemment
ça me paraît nécessaire de travailler
sur sur le son de
ces problèmes quand vous vous auriez
vous seriez tenté d'aller demander des
comptes aux parents justement un de
certains traitements de deux de ces
mineurs peut-être je pense que la
justice se fera ça me paraît nécessaire
quand vous voyez des comportements des
instants de vie qui sont prévues dans le
code sont dépeintes fortes qui peuvent
être appliqués à 110 et plusieurs années
de prison noire dans le code pénal je
pense que c'est nécessaire de 2,2
rendent responsable également ou de
poser la responsabilité d'aider des
parents lorsqu'il s'agit des mineurs les
adultes c'est autre chose
responsabilité mais également on voit
très bien que l'argent s'il est bien on
voit les conséquences ou là des jeunes
parallèlement qui font des efforts pour
des études pour des formations pour un
cursus de travail et là je trouve que
c'est très positif et puis vous avez une
petite minorité quelques individus qui
ne veulent pas entrer dans ce dispositif
qui ne veulent pas respecter les valeurs
républicaines parce que quand vous avez
une insécurité ben vous mettez en cause
les libertés individuelles et
collectives également des habitants on
voit malheureusement de cette minorité
qui se multiplient dans plusieurs villes
de france il ya eu des incidents quasi
similaire il ya deux jours à lyon
d'ailleurs le votre homologue 1 vers
l'europe écologie les verts
grégory nous tous et nous disait qu'en
gros il y avait assez de vidéos caméras
surveillance qu'il allait faire même un
audit pour connaître évidemment leur
utilité vous n'êtes pas du tout dans le
même discours par rapport aux aux
caméras aujourd'hui vous en demandez
peut-être plus encore parce que j'ai
installé sur la ville puis une ville
moyenne plus de 60 caméras vidéo
protection et donc nous allons encore
renforcer le dispositif parce que les
caméras permettent effectivement de
capter des images
les auteurs
[Musique]
voilà rond
on arrive en tout cas la fin de cette
interview et on a compris donc vous
allez renforcer encore ce dispositif de
vidéo caméra surveillance
en tout cas le n8 son côté 1 pour une
autre élection a appelé à rétablir
l'ordre et la sécurité dans les
quartiers vous êtes sur cette ligne on
n'attendait pas forcément un socialiste
sur ce thème vous vous rejoignez en tout
cas dans cette demande aujourd'hui de
fermeté contre une minorité et moi je
suis un élu républicain
ce discours que j'ai aujourd'hui je l'
ai toujours eues c'est pas nouveau parce
que malheureusement j'ai été confronté
également à des événements ya quelques
années par rapport à des violences
urbaines donc la question de fond qu'on
doit se poser c'est l'application de nos
lois républicaines elle doit s'appliquer
partout sur tous les territoires mais
c'est pas mon avis une question de
gauche ou de droite moi je pense que
nous devrions avoir un consensus sur
cette sécurité qui est indispensable
pour nos libertés voilà ce que ce que je
peux dire alors si des hommes politiques
de droite et de gauche se rejoignent sur
ce sujet là c'est une bonne chose ça
veut dire qu'il faudra renforcer encore
les dispositifs renforcer les moyens de
la police ya eu des efforts de fait pour
le reconnaître pourra continuer
renforcer les moyens de la justice j'ai
écouté le garde des sceaux récemment il
a indiqué que dans le budget 2022
n'aurait effectivement des des renforts
c'est une bonne chose donc il faut de
travailler parce qu'on voit très bien
que les conséquences sont graves ça ça
d'élite notre société ça met en cause
les valeurs républicaines pour lequel
nous sommes particulièrement attachés là
ça veut dire de la rigueur ça veut dire
de la détermination celle ça veut dire
également de la fermeté y compris dans
les sanctions merci beaucoup l'aqim
fillon d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france un maire ps d'alençon
se dirige-t-on vers une diminution des
logements sociaux en france et en aucun
objet d une circulaire ministérielle qui
pourrait prochainement être validé par
une loi sont concernés les villes qui
comptent plus de 40% de ce type
d'appartement n'est déjà des razak
nous sommes à bagneux dans les
hauts-de-seine la ville compte plus de
60 9 % de logement social et c'est
beaucoup pour le gouvernement qui veut
prendre la main sur la construction de
ces habitations à loyer modéré la
décision d'accorder ou non un permis de
construire appartient 1 jusqu'à présent
aux maires des villes concernées mais ça
pourrait en être autrement à l'avenir
l'objectif est de n'autoriser la
délivrance de ces agréments que dans des
cas très limités en vue d'assurer la
cohérence de l'action de l'état au titre
de renouvellement urbain de la
requalification des îlots dégradés de
l'aménagement des quartiers proches de
grandes infrastructures de transport ou
de la mise en oeuvre du plan égalité des
chances partie intégrante de l'ensemble
des mesures décidées lors du comité
interministériel des villes cette mesure
doit contribuer à améliorer les
conditions de vie nos concitoyens et à
lutter contre le sentiment de relégation
une proposition de loi des sénateurs is
dominique estrosi et valérie létard qui
doit être discutée début décembre à
l'assemblée nationale va dans ce sens
qu'elle vise à donner au gouvernement la
décision pour la production de logements
sociaux dans les communes qui en compte
plus de 40 % et faut dire qu'il y en a
beaucoup 43 villes sont concernées en
ile-de-france et dans l'oise le taux de
logement social atteint 69% à dugny 61%
à l'île saint denis ou encore 56% à
trappes et à bonneuil-sur-marne l ile de
france regroupe un million trois cent
mille logements locatifs sociaux et
c'est un quart du parc national et
pourtant l'offre est très loin de
répondre aux besoins en 2019 dans la
région sept cent trente six mille
demandes étaient enregistrées pour
seulement 72 mille attributions dont
l'oise où nous enregistrons 5000
demandes en attente
si nous nous construisons plus où est ce
que les gens vont habiter on marche sur
la tête il y à 700 mille demandes de
logements sociaux rien qu'en
ile-de-france la construction de hlm est
en chute libre depuis que macro et
président et voilà que maintenant ils
veulent s'attaquer au maire qui en font
trop malgré la forte demande ce que
souhaite l'une des deux sénatrices à
l'origine de la proposition de loi c'est
d'éviter je cite de créer des ghettos on
ne dit pas qu'il ne faut plus construire
ce type de logement mais évitons d'en
faire là où il y en a déjà une forte
concentration au risque de créer des
ghettos il ne faut pas rajouter de la
pauvreté à la pauvreté d'accord mais
cela ne règle pas le problème de ceux
qui attendent un logement social
certains depuis dix ans et puis chili à
certaines villes dites riches au faible
taux de logement social qui refuse d'en
construire davantage une centaine d'élus
de gauche d'île de france ont annoncé
leur intention de manifester le 10
novembre devant le ministère du logement
pour dénoncer la situation je cite
catastrophique du logement en france il
souhaite placer ce qu'ils appellent
une urgence absolue au centre du débat
de la campagne présidentielle
dans l'actualité également un médiateur
à calais pour dialoguer avec les
associations des dom iguerande le patron
de l'office français de l'immigration et
de l'intégration a été envoyé en mission
par le gouvernement premiers contacts
pris avec le prêtre et les deux
militants associatifs en grève de la
faim un mouvement entamé il ya 17 jours
pour soutenir les migrants ils demandent
aussi la suspension des expulsions
quotidiennes de migrants sur le littoral
nord de l'hexagone à
il y à un dialogue à construire ensemble
pour arriver à une meilleure prise en
charge des personnes qui stationnent à
calais tout en évitant la reconstitution
d'une land comme on a eu il ya
maintenant six ans calais c'est une
situation complexe peut être qu'un
regard extérieur permettra de mieux
mesurer les enjeux les écarts entre les
différentes positions et à partir de là
construire une solution et pour en
parler nous sommes avec pierre henry
président de france paternité bonsoir
pierre henri mérou soit avec nous nous
avons eu l'occasion il ya quelques jours
un d'évoquer la situation dramatique de
ces migrants à calais il faut qu' on en
arrive à des grèves de la faim pour que
l'état envoie un médiateur
côté il ya une situation qui dure depuis
près de 20 ans a calé et tout simplement
parce que vous avez un certain nombre de
gens là qui viennent d'irak de syrie
qui viennent du yémen
et qui veulent se rendre en
grande-bretagne alors il ya eu des
épisodes successifs
sangatte qu'elle est calé dans je vous
rappelle qui a été évacué le camp de
calais qui a été évacuée il ya cinq ans
dix mille personnes est aujourd'hui
toujours des gens qui se concentre sur
le littoral calaisien pour rejoindre la
grande bretagne le problème est le
suivant c'est que évidemment les
autorités le maire de calais ne veulent
surtout pas de la reconstitution d'un
camp il ya une offre de logement qui est
proposé aux
migrants aux demandeurs d'asile qui sont
là bas mais qui n'est pas toujours
acceptés qui n'est pas toujours en
nombre suffisant et donc les ont pas
toujours acceptée c'est important ce que
vous nous dites parce que c'est d'accord
évidemment on n'a pas la connaissance du
terrain comme vous l'avez on se dit on
et laisse là on la propose rien donc
vous me dites y'a vraiment des des
solutions alors via des propositions qui
sont faites évidemment d'hébergement
mais qui se situe à 100 km 200 km 300
kilomètres de calais or le but est
évident c'est passé de l'autre côté en
grande bretagne et puis je précis j'ai
j'insiste là dessus il n'y a pas
suffisamment de place de proposer et
donc vous avez une mission qui est
donnée à la police qui est en permanence
d'empêcher toute reconstitution de caen
donc ça donne évidemment des tensions et
le grand problème c'est
de
de réussir à respecter la dignité des
personnes et les règles d'admission sur
le territoire le problème est le suivant
aussi c'est que la grande bretagne a
externalisé sa politique migratoire à
sous traiter sa politique migratoire à
la france et donc ça donne ces tensions
mais vous savez le dernier check
d'ailleurs à
bassam et oui bien sûr bien sûr il ya
des traités qui ont été qui sont
continuellement révisé et il ya de
l'argent sonnant et trébuchant qui est
donné
pour
pour sécuriser
l'ensemble de la frontière mais qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire puis vous savez pour
ces migrants est temps de passer de
l'autre côté est-ce que c'est avec de
l'argent que la france va réussir à
gérer cette crise mais la france n'y
arrive pas mais je vais vous dire il y a
un problème à toutes les frontières dans
l'espace monde il ya une crispation
autour des territoires nationaux
c'est vrai à la frontière polonaise avec
la biélorussie
c'est vrai en libye c'est vrai en italie
avec les gens qui viennent justement de
libye de tunisie etc c'est vrai partout
est
l'une des solutions c'est d'ouvrir des
voies de migration légale pour par
exemple
les mineurs qui arrive à calais il y en
a un qui ont de la famille de l'autre
côté et plutôt que de leur faire courir
le risque de
risque et le risque de leur vie dans la
manche sur des rafiots
d'entretenir des passeurs nous avions
essayé et moi personnellement il ya cinq
ans nous avions négocié avec le
gouvernement britannique
une voie de migration légale je crois
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre solution bi
fouras pire délinquant donc ça a donné
quoi bon aujourd'hui avec une brique se
bat là-bas ça aide dès que tout s'est
arrêté et que le break si tu étais un
énorme bond sauge parce que je vous
rappelle que le break site a été vendu
la population britannique sur l'idée il
y aura plus de migration et oui mais
sauf que depuis le début de l'année il y
a dix huit mille personnes qui ont tenté
le passage le passage et dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles il y a
des morts
chaque chaque mois à calais les
frontières
font
mourir un certain nombre de personnes
n'y a pas de solution simple donc mais
il y a des droits il ya un droit
inaliénable à demander les il est par
exemple a calé il ya des gens qui
peuvent demander l'asile en grande
bretagne la grande bretagne se paye de
mots par exemple au moment de la crise
en afghanistan j'ai entendu boris
johnson expliqué que d'aller cueillir
vingt mille réfugiés en provenance
d'afghanistan bravo mais juste de
l'autre côté de la frontière il ya des
gens qui attendent et qui ont des droits
à faire valoir
de l'autre côté donc il ya ceux qui vont
prendre la part alors par ces
britanniques des bars et écouter et
manifestement il semble pas décidé à le
faire avec la france puisqu'ils
considèrent qu'il paie et mais l'europe
l'union européenne fait la même chose
dès que la turquie parce que erdogan
joue évidemment de la pression des
migrants sur l'union européenne mais la
pologne fait la même chose et la
biélorussie fait la même chose en
prenant en otage un certain des milliers
de migrants qui sont aujourd'hui dans
des forêts frontière donc c'est une
espèce de figure
planétaire avec laquelle
nous avons fr et donc voilà nous avons
le choix de la dignité et du respect des
règles et je pense que nous pouvons
faire les deux voilà parce que
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe du côté de
kehl et
c'est une certaine forme d'un dignité ce
n'est pas possible de
continuer comme ça d'abord parce que
c'est inefficace vous savez le passage
pour aller vers la grande bretagne c'est
aujourd'hui 2000 2500 euros pour risquer
sa vie sur un rafiot pour aller 17 km de
l'autre côté et plus vous fermez plus
les routes migratoires
sans chérissent donc voilà oui c'est
normal qu'un état donne un certain
nombre de règles mais je crois qu'il
doit toujours avoir en tête le respect
de la dignité des personnes merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci votre invitation le fichage et des
types des français sous les 2 es cour
européenne des droits de l'homme doit se
prononcer sur le fichier national des
empreintes digitales un stock de profils
génétiques toujours plus importants
problèmes ils concernent surtout une
majorité de personne jamais condamnée
des explications de guémar aussi on ne
vous le souhaite pas mais si un jour
vous commettez un crime ou un délit il y
a de fortes chances qu'on vous
soumettent à un prélèvement biologique
pas pour détecter si vous avez le coc
vide non plus tôt pour enregistrer et
stocker votre profil génétique ces
informations vous concernant iront
rejoindre un immense fichiers le fnaeg
le fichier national automatisé des
empreintes génétiques
or ce fichage il n'a rien d'anodin en
pratique la police relève aujourd'hui
systématiquement l'adn de toute personne
en garde à vue nonobstant la présomption
d'innocence qui est un des piliers du
droit pénal sachant que le simple fait
de conserver les empreintes génétiques
d'une personne est susceptible de la
stigmatiser ou de créer une
discrimination à son encontre se pose la
question de savoir si ces pratiques ne
constitue pas une atteinte
disproportionnée à la protection des
droits et libertés des personnes et
c'est bien pour ça que de nombreuses
personnes souvent des militants
politiques ou associatifs refuse de se
soumettre à ce prélèvement sauf que ce
refus est bien en réalité c'est un délit
passible d'un an de prison et de 15000
euros d'amendé et oui c'est prévu par
l'article 706 56 du code de procédure
pénal la peine et même doubler si ce
refus provient d'une personne condamnée
pour un crime hors du côté de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme on est
plutôt critique vis-à-vis de ce fichier
français des empreintes génétiques
aucune différenciation est actuellement
prévu en fonction de la nature et de la
gravité de l'infraction commise malgré
l'importante disparité des situations
susceptibles de se présenter et oui il
se trouve que dans cette affaire de
fichage tout le monde est un peu logés à
la même enseigne et ce quelle que soit
l'infraction commise que vous ayez tué
15 personnes ou casser un abribus paf
quarante années d'inscription de vos
informations génétiques fnaeg y compris
si vous avez participé à une
manifestation non autorisée certes un
gilet jaune pourrait vous en parler
alors que cela ne constitue pas en soi
un délit justifiant le fichage créant 98
de suite au meurtre de guy georges le
fichier national automatisé des
empreintes génétiques ne concernait
initialement que les personnes
condamnées pour des infractions
sexuelles depuis la liste des
infractions visées s'est allongée en
même temps que le nombre de personnes
fichées de près de 3000 il y a deux
décennies à près de 5,6 millions
aujourd'hui dont les trois quarts
environ ne sont que des personnes
suspectées mais jamais condamné est en
réalité ces chiffres sont virtuellement
bien plus élevé cette situation soulève
également des inquiétudes sur les
atteintes à la vie privée de personnes
qui ne sont pas directement concernés
dont le nombre est très important en
effet la présence de l'adn d'une
personne renseigne de façon fiable sur
ses deux parents biologiques ainsi que
sur ses enfants le coefficient
multiplicateur entre le nombre de
personnes présentes et celle qu'il est
possible d'impliquer directement ou
indirectement et de 5,1 en incluant la
recherche en parentèle indirects ce
coefficient peut s'élever jusqu'à 6,2 ce
qui signifie que d'un tiers à la moitié
de la population française est
potentiellement identifiable via ce
fichier et l'exécutif ne semble pas
pressé de s'atteler à cette question
épineuse selon mediapart personne n'a
encore pris la peine de 10g le décret
censé définir les conditions de stockage
des profils génétiques en revanche les
sénateurs de la majorité présidentielle
ont bien pensé à ajouter de nouvelles
infractions justifiant une inscription
au fnaeg puisqu'ils ont fait adopter un
amendement en ce sens il y à peine de se
mettre plus que jamais le pacte
républicain semble s'émousser dans une
ère numérique toute puissante et qui ne
cache plus ses tentations de fichage
tous azimuts quitte à renier sans
complexe sur les libertés individuelles
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi rendez vous dès demain
pour un nouveau numéro en attendant
l'actualité continue sur rt france toute
la soirée
[Musique]
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]